-Our next guest is an Academy
Award-nominated director.
His film "Postcard from Earth"
is showing exclusively
at The Sphere in Las Vegas.
Please welcome to the show
Darren Aronofsky.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
I'm very excited to talk about
this technical marvel of a film,
but I also want to start.
The first time I became aware
of you was your film "Pi,"
which came out in the late '90s,
which is a wonderful film.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We just had
our 25th anniversary.
-Just had the 25th.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You made this movie
for $60,000?
-Yeah. Pretty much.
-And so it was
a very lo-fi film.
It was just, like, cut and run.
You made it.
But it was great storytelling,
and it was
the beginning of things.
And now this is so different,
what you did with this.
-How things change.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, The Sphere is in Las Vegas.
-Yeah.
Everyone's seen that thing.
-There you go.
-Yeah.
-And so when they first
approached you, like, what did
you know about this sphere?
-I knew it was a crazy idea.
-Yeah.
-But I couldn't really imagine
what a TV screen
four football fields large
would feel like.
I actually didn't get to see it
till August of this year.
That was the first time
they turned it on.
And so we had been working
on these crazy images,
and then suddenly,
to see it everywhere,
was a wild journey.
-So, you filmed this movie
not quite being able to conceive
of what it would look
like when projected.
-It was a lot of guesswork.
It was kind of shooting blind.
It was described
like flying the airplane
while building it,
and it was very much that.
'Cause the technology
didn't quite exist
and how we were going
to actually interpret
all that data.
So, the camera outputs
32 gigs per second.
So like a movie on your
hard drive is three gigs.
So this is 30 gigs --
32 gigs per second
to make an 18K image.
So the amount of information
was just --
it was kind of mind-blowing.
-What was the size
of the camera?
[ Laughter ]
-So -- exactly.
It took about
12 people to turn this camera on
because there was, like, fans
and overheating.
And then, the final file
of the film
is what they call
a half a petabyte.
-Okay.
-So that's after terabyte
is now a petabyte.
I guess we'll all start...
-So, like, you
probably had to, like,
use Maildrop to send it.
-Exactly, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Re-transfer, please.
Yeah.
-And so I also want to --
So, the exterior of the --
And again, I was seeing images
of The Sphere online,
and I didn't quite comprehend
what I was seeing, but...
-Yeah.
So this is actually a 2K image.
-Okay.
-So that's 2K.
We're 18K on the inside.
-All right.
So just to give a sense
of what you can do with 2K...
Like, that's --
I mean, if you see that
you realize --
-That's a real image.
-I know.
And that's, like,
if you're in Vegas,
you have a late night in Vegas,
and you wake up...
[ Laughter ]
-It's true.
This is Summer League.
That's crazy.
That is, uh...
-Yeah, that's --
that's a very popular one.
-That's a very popular one.
And this is,
U2 is doing a concert there.
And then, the other...
-Attraction.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is your film.
-When U2's not there,
we're there.
Basically the thing.
-It's not the other way around?
-No, they got first dibs
on everything.
-Okay, good.
-It's good. All respect.
-Yeah, yeah, very much so.
But, so the first time
the audience saw 18K...
-Yeah.
-...and somebody
posted on Instagram.
-Oh, yeah.
-Can you talk about
the moment as you, a director --
You hadn't seen this technology
until recently, as well.
What was it like?
-It was great.
It was -- it was
what we were hoping for.
So, no one had ever seen it,
so we didn't really know
what they would respond.
And then this moment happened,
and it was just, like...
I don't know.
You always hope --
I actually didn't know that
jaw-dropping was a real thing.
You hear that word, but it's fun
to look around,
and people are just like --
their jaws are literally --
literally dropped,
and they're all pointing
at different places
on the screen.
So it's a joy to be --
to kind of have audiences
go along for that trip.
-Let's just take a look
at this short video
just to see the reaction
to the first time seeing 18K.
♪♪
Whoa!
[ Audience exclaims, applause ]
-This is crazy.
♪♪
-Yeah.
-We have to stress, of course,
that's on someone's phone.
-Yes, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not what it's gonna
look like for you guys.
It's true. It's --
I was trying to shoot --
I was lucky enough to post
the first images of it,
and I just --
I was sitting in that room
forever trying
to get a good image,
and not to diss iPhone,
but it just wasn't...
-No. Well, I mean, I guess
that's why it is an attraction
worth going to see,
because there's no way to see it
unless you're actually there
in person.
-Yeah. And so --
and it's a strange thing
to try to tell people
what it's like,
but it's -- it's kind of
a nature film
where we shot in every continent
on the planet --
we went to the Antarctic,
we went to Australia,
we went everywhere -- and just
shot just the coolest stuff
that you could imagine
but with a resolution
that's hard to sort of take in.
And we also actually
shot micro images.
We shot -- there's one shot
of a praying mantis.
And most people, when you think
of a praying mantis,
you're like with
a magnifying glass
or you're really close,
staring at it.
But this is a 150-foot tall
praying mantis, fully in focus.
And so you could look at it --
And so it's not like
anything you've seen before.
It's pretty cool.
-Now, nature --
You've actually done some
sort of nature filming
before this, as well.
Was that something -- when
you first got into filmmaking,
is that a path you thought
you would maybe take?
-I come from that background.
I was originally trained
as a field biologist.
Strangely enough, I did a bunch
of research out in nature,
and I've been kind of connected
to lots of green groups
over the years.
And then, a really
smart executive
remembered that about my bio
and connected me
with a show called
"One Strange Rock,"
and it led to
"Welcome to Earth"
and "Limitless"
and all this Nat Geo work I do.
So, when this came along,
I was --
I was able to get
the best people in the business
to come work on it with us.
-How did you find your way
into filmmaking?
Was that something
that came to you in college?
-Yeah.
I went to college, and I
really didn't know how to write,
and my roommate was making
animation cartoons,
and he was getting A's,
and I was getting B's,
and I was like,
"Oh, maybe I should start
taking drawing classes."
So that's how it started.
-And when you go out
in nature,
especially, again,
when you have this camera
that no one's ever used
before...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...I mean, are you just --
is it so thrilling to know
that you're going to find
the things
that you would want people
to see for the first time?
-Yeah. It's hard.
It was a very -- it was
kind of a jigsaw puzzle in --
because the camera was
really unwieldy.
It was very --
-I can't believe
the praying mantis, like,
stayed still for a shot.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, I think you had
to shoot things that were --
that -- that held still, and,
like, a praying mantis,
after it eats something
sort of sits there
for a while, digesting,
so that's when we shot it.
[ Laughter ]
But you look
for things like that.
We tried to move the camera
a few times.
It's very tricky.
And then, we did a lot
of really cool stuff.
We attached it to a --
to a helicopter
and flew it around for a while,
which was -- which was great
because I got to do that
with these incredible pilots.
And we were up in Oregon
when there was
all these incredible
forest fires,
and we were just flying over
the most incredible landscape
and just knowing
we were capturing it
with something that looked as
real as what we were seeing.
-So obviously, you love nature,
you love being in the outdoors.
How did you enjoy your time
in Las Vegas?
[ Laughter ]
-There's a lot of -- a lot
of great talent comes through.
I saw Adele twice,
so I can't -- I can't whine.
It was an amazing show.
I saw Copperfield, I saw --
I just tried to take
in all the different things.
-How much time did you have
to actually
technically spend
in Las Vegas?
-Too much, but I think it was --
But there is --
There's also the Pinball
Hall of Fame, which is --
-Yeah. I have friends
who've gone
to the Pinball Hall of Fame.
-It's amazing.
-Do you have
a favorite pinball game?
-Oh, that's a good question.
It depends what era.
What?
But the old school,
it was a game called "Taxi,"
where you have to
pick up Gorbachev.
-Yeah. Oh.
-Old school, you know.
-He was in a --
-"Taxi" plus "Gorbachev" --
I think we know when it's from.
-Exactly.
And then --
But, you know,
I got into "The Twilight Zone"
game this last time.
-"Medieval Madness"?
You ever play "Medieval..."
-Love it, love it.
-That's a great game.
-Great game, yeah.
-All right.
I think when you tell people you
went to Vegas, and they're like,
"What'd you do?"
you're like, "Pinball, baby,"
they're like, "Oh. You're the
wrong person to go to Vegas."
-I did have a run, though,
after --
So, like, after the premiere,
and people really liked it,
and I was at the casino --
I don't gamble --
and my friends
were at the table all losing,
and I was like, "You know what?
All this, like,
positive energy is my way."
And I did a run,
and I walked out
with 800 bucks in my pocket.
-800 bucks?
That's fantastic.
-Boom!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how many --
That's how crazy the pixels are.
There's more pixels than there
are money you won in Vegas.
-Exactly, exactly.
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
I really can't wait to
see it live.
Darren Aronofsky, everybody.
"Postcard from Earth"
showing exclusive
at The Sphere in Las Vegas.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."